when we do get a new Stargate on our
screens will it still really be Stargate
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so after dropping the news again
exclusively that Mark Fergus would be
the new show on it for a new Stargate
series and potentially movie in the New
Year I've had lots and lots of comments
and lots of those comments are basically
said it won't be Stargate it won't look
like stagger it won't feel like Stargate
so why the hell should I watch this
rubbish now for one I'm going to say
it's the same argument I had to Lord of
the Rings it's not even been officially
announced yet it's not been made yet so
how can we really judge it yet so let's
let's put a cork in that right now we
can't judge a series that's not even
been done yet I'm even getting some
comments saying it's going to be a woke
mess and that Hollywood can't make a TV
series like this anymore
I would disagree and to be honest I'm
really excited that Mark Fergus and Hawk
osterby are involved in this project
because I saw what they did with the
expanse they did a really respectful TV
show that really respected the original
content they made it in a believable
realistic way and that's really
important because Stargate always had
that feel as well didn't it it always
had that realism that it could to be
honest that was always part of a big
charm for me and the difference between
Stargate and Star Trek is that Stargate
could have actually been happening in
the expanse there was always the same
sort of feel that it was realistic so if
assuming the hawk OSP and Mark Ferguson
nothing goes wrong and they get to make
the show they want to make then I don't
see any reason why it would be any
different
don't forget to like subscribe and share
the video with all of your other Gator
friends also you go to side
hashtrack.com for brilliant Stargate
related merch just like this you can
even buy socks and don't forget the
Sidetrack sides Channel where I do loads
of little live videos and other fun
stuff all the links are in the
description also in the injection of
humor into the series I fully expect
Mark Ferguson Hawk Coast be to do
exactly the same because they've done it
with other projects again Matt's done a
video all about this talking about the
different things that Hawk Coast B and
Matt figures have done in the past the
sort of writing they've done and
hopefully a nice in-depth look at what
we can then expect them to do with
Stargate they're not going to completely
change their spots they're going to do
very similar to what they've done in the
past just go and watch Iron Man there is
an injection of humor throughout that
movie but also an injection of realism
something that I think has generally
been lost in Marvel movies since and
obviously Mark Fergus wrote that script
so I expect them to continue along that
form and to continue making a TV show
that is most realistic and humorous it's
probably one of the reasons why Mark
Fergus was so Keen to do Stargate in the
first place because I imagine he looks
back at sg1 and just thinks yeah that's
the sort of thing I could really sink my
teeth into that's got a bit of me
written all over it because that's the
sort of thing I'm good at
so again I think we've got to give them
an opportunity to really make something
new now as I did say in the previous
video um when I was talking about Canon
a bit more
in lots of ways this isn't going to feel
like the Stargate we had you know we've
got the whole thing about this on a
streaming service now it's going to be
in 10 or 12 episodes it's going to have
a much bigger budget which is going to
again affect the feel of the show
overall but also it's been 15 years
since Stargate was on our screens it's
going to be different
but I actually honestly trust Mark
Fergus to keep to the roots of what
Stargate made Stargate and actually
something I think they forgot about when
they did SGU I thoroughly expect them to
continue along the lines of it being a
realistic TV show based and grounded in
some sort of realism but also I really
expect them to inject the humor into the
show even in the expanse there was quite
a dark humor and that's something I've
always really really appreciated to be
honest
um you can only see TV shows and oh
they're so down to earth and they're so
grounded and all the drama and you know
they're so realistic but there's no
humor in it I always say well that's not
realistic I I've always worked in quite
stressful jobs and you know when things
get really dark that tends to be When
people's dark sense of humor comes out
it's how we cope with things so somebody
will be in the background making
sarcastic comments maybe quietly between
themselves but they'll still be there we
need a character like Jack O'Neill we
need the relation ships and the people
to bounce off each other like a family
and let's be honest families take the
piss out of each other all the time so
why wouldn't they in a future Stargate
series just like they did in sg1 and SG
Atlantis
so again
I know also that Mark Fergus is a
massive Stargate fan I've been able to
dig out a few interviews when he's
actually talked to my Stargate in the
past and let's remember as well that he
was asked by Amazon what do you want to
do and he said I'd love to do Stargate
pretty much from that meeting onwards it
was always going to be him they didn't
want Brad for whatever reason I actually
think Brad made a little tweet about
ageism in his industry and in the
writing industry and I actually think
he's right I think Amazon completely
ignored even the possibility of bringing
Brad on as a writer and a Creator simply
because they think he's passed it and
they wanted somebody younger now I hope
that Mark Fergus and I expect him to to
be honest will reach out to Brad Wright
and Brad Wright I think would be
desperate to get involved in some way
even if it was just a consultancy role
and I actually thoroughly expect Mark
Fergus to be involved in that way Mark
Fergus again and Amazon are very aware
about the social social media they see
all the tweets and they see all the
videos like this and they see us talking
online and they know that a big part of
the community aren't desperate for power
to return and actually are threatening
to basically boycott any new TV show if
he doesn't
and if that happens and Brad Wright does
come back and at least in a consultancy
role which I actually generally believe
he would I remember there were stories
about the original Stargate and he
actually tried to get Dean Devlin
enrolled in Emerick to talk to them to
work with them on sg1 and they refuse
they sort of said no where the movies
your TV in there
I actually think Brad Wright's a big
enough man and 100 I think he is that if
he was offered some sort of role like
that he would jump at it he wouldn't
just go well I know that's my Stargate
you're not messing with it I think he
would come on and he he loves stargazing
which is we do let's be honest I think
he would come on and he would say
and he would help them basically he
would come on in he would help them make
a show that we'll love so will Stargate
still be Stargate if Amazon let Mark
Fergus actually do the job that I know
he's capable of doing yes it will be
if Mark Fergus has got enough sense to
bring Brad Wright on in some capacity
yes it will be if Amazon dictate to Mark
Fergus and Hawk ospi though what this
show is supposed to be and if they just
think about the new audience they think
they're going to attract and forget
about your skaters then yeah this could
be an absolute [ __ ]
but I am hopeful because I've got to be
this is a TV show I adore and I can't
wait to have back on our screens so the
moment I am going to lock the negativity
out I am not going to allow it into my
brain I am going to stay positive
because this Stargate Series has been
something I've been waiting for for a
very very long time and it will be
awesome it will be
I hope
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you enjoy the content and you want to
become a fully fledged side tracker
please hit the join Button as always
please stay safe it's coming home Gators
I'll see you next time
[Music]